[Music]
this place is my repetition my legacy
will the smoke clears I promise you will
be the king she over the key blood
everywhere none of it his he had bullet
holes in his shirt how did he not get
hit that shotgun blast on long sheet of
Julia you're amazing I don't want to be
different than anybody else
people need you cops can only do so much
Harlem's about control power politics is
where the power is his necks just like
me that let you hold on to what you've
got you never really know what anyone is
capable of
[Music]
there is nothing that can hurt you so
what the hell are you our freedom Oh big
money playboy your time's up wait up
Jenkins ruse is nuts
is queen y'all got hit last night
everybody
you need to take time is weakness and
you squeeze don't be a hero
another hero type looks to me like
that's what you've always been
now take you to war you don't have
enough people you want some
laptop of this issue
oh man it's you oh man PLO Styles my joy
back in the day and sweet Christmas you
double XL oh yeah do you want me you
should be out there helping people you
think I ask me any of this I was putting
some tank like exotic fish came out with
ability